chris what's the uh last couple days  been like have there been any  uh phone calls of note or text that  really meant a lot to you  and when you see the signatures  behind you like nba finals what does  that really mean to finally be here  um it's different obviously having  practice here not at the  practice facility but it's still  basketball i think we all locked into  you know the goal at hand and excuse me  um  not much just i don't know  it's weird no games being on i usually  watch  games every day so that's probably the  part that sucks that's probably the part  that sucks the most but i'd rather be  playing and not  but other than that just life  and